muttersein heute
was heißt das
wenigste liebe und hingabe eines glück
oder auch selbstaufgabe
verlust von autonomie und identität
mütter sind haupt forschungsgegenstand
von christina mundlos deutsche
soziologin und mutter sie will nicht
dass wir zeigen wo sie wohnt seit sie an
ihrem neuesten buch arbeitet kriegt sie
drohschreiben anscheinend hat sie sich
an ein gruseliges thema gewagt
unglückliche und bereuen die mütter
viele menschen ursprung von mundlos
nachforschungen ist die studie der
israelische soziologin ordner donath
recruiting mother road mutterschaft
bereuen sie löste letztes jahr hitzige
debatten im internet aus daraufhin hat
muss auch im deutschsprachigen raum
beruhende mütter befragt manche aus der
überforderung heraus anderer ganz
grundsätzlich frauen mit verschiedenem
hintergrund und alter
die bräune mütter haben sehr ambivalente
gefühle
sie lieben ihre kinder aber sind
gleichzeitig sehr unglücklich mit der
mutterrolle und da steckt natürlich eine
gewisse dramatik drin denn sie wollen
sich natürlich nicht von ihren kindern
trennen oder lösen man kann die
mutterschaft auch nicht rückgängig
machen müssen also trotzdem in dieser
unglücklichen rolle verharren
mütter die bereuen rütteln an den
grundfesten der gesellschaft erzählt
auch der mutter mythos von der
hingebungsvollen bedürfnis freien mutter
von mutterschaft als einzig wirklichen
hort für die glückseligkeit der frau
evolutionstechnisch ihrer lebens
bestimmen wer das nicht ehrt ist
selbstsüchtig asozial ja nicht ganz
normal sagen kritiker
andere solidarisieren sich sehen die
debatte als längst fälligen einwand
gegen verklärten kinder kitsch als
befreiungsschlag und wichtigen schritt
für den feminismus
wir können aus der debatte über die
bräune mütter lernen und mitnehmen dass
es den natürlichen mutterinstinkt nicht
gibt sondern dass das ein soziales
konstrukt ist und dass wir deshalb auch
männern fürsorge tätigkeiten zu trauen
sollten sie daran führen sollten und
akzeptieren sollten wenn frauen
berufstätig sind und da ihre prioritäten
lägen und wenn männer zu hause bei den
kindern bleiben auch wenn die
gleichstellungs debatte eine lange
führte ist verändert hat sich in den
letzten jahren wenig außer der anspruch
an die moderne mutterschaft
sagt autorin sibylle stillhart ihre drei
kinder bereut sie nicht versteht aber
sehr wohl wie es dazu kommen kann dass
frau in ihrer mutterrolle auf
unterschiedlichste art und weise
hinterfragen oder bereuen karriere küche
kinder gesund füttern pädagogisch
fördern ihr seelenheil waren
das sind zwei leben an einem tag so dass
man die konservativen im hamsterrad
müsse der druck genommen werden damit
sie sich nicht permanent als defizitär
und schreit und erlebten sagt stillhart
für glückliche familien brauche es
entscheidende strukturelle veränderungen
eines entwicklungslandes friberg vorwurf
und familie anbelangt und das verwundert
mich eigentlich nach wie vor reichsten
länder der welt und ich freue mich
wirklich warum ist warum muss sich die
gesellschaft auch ich sind
wirtschaftlich so schwertut für
familienfreundliche strukturen
muttersein heute was heißt das
hmm